on est de parler de la persévérance et
j'ai traduit de la persévérance pour
accomplir accomplir pour réaliser pour
créer et je suis très heureuse de
m'exprimer ainsi
devant les étudiants de l'école
mohammedia d'ingénieurs
cela me rappelle à moi même le temps où
j'étais étudiant en économie à
l'université de rabat bah c'était il ya
presque cinquante ans durant toutes ces
années je ne suis pas du tout interrogé
sur le thème de la persévérance et il a
faim de cette réunion pour que jardin un
petit peu dans les proviseurs de la vie
et que je me dise et j'étais une égide a
été persévérant et pas je vais vous dire
que malgré une réflexion
ce soir je ne sais pas quoi vous
répondre mais peut-être que après avoir
fait exploser pour venir et fils et
persévérant
donc je souhaitais de présenter quelques
fautes on est juste des photos qui
montrent des hommes en train d'accomplir
justement et c'est au moins un point
commun un seul point
c'est justement cette persévérance c'est
un symbole le symbole eh oui naturel
mais en fait qu'est ce que c'est que la
persévérance heures peut-être que je
suis un peu trop scolaire que je la
perte est un dictionnaire et j'ai trouvé
dans la fiction définition du
dictionnaire c'est mettre en oeuvre sa
volonté et de patience pour poursuivre
menace mais poursuivre action crier puis
je serai sur scène quelques citations
ans et jamais dans les stations de
trouver des choses intéressantes
et voilà la première la persévérance et
la noblesse de l'obstination puis un
proverbe français
la persévérance bien à vous de tous et
bruits en intervention serez mien et
râteaux newman est perseverare qui
abrite on veut dire l'erreur est humaine
mais persévérer est diabolique
et puis j'ai trouvé quelque chose qui
m'a vraiment plu les batailles de la vie
nous aura gagné marais plus fort ni par
les plus rapides mais parce qu'ils
n'abandonnent jamais et ça c'était un
registre hassan 2
j'ai donc décidé un peu plus tard de
près
les avocats severan sur un trafic car je
sais que vous les élèves de l'école
d'ingénieurs vous n'avez pas de secret
avec les mathématiques
j'ai proposé sur boukari deux axes la
vie de la volonté
opposé à la de l'absence de volonté
c'est la folie la kz2 l'égoïsme à
l'absence de la cruche à l'eau de vie
sont de la truite et j'ai passé le mot
persévérance entre la poésie de mettre
quelques mots qui tourne autour de
persévérance en regroupant égoïsme et
volonté on obtient opiniâtreté et pire
encore obstination si on met volonté
plus ou moins détruits ça donne
acharnement et ténacité à une volonté
mais de l'égoïsme ça positionne
l'apathie et peu de volonté et la crise
y définit la l'espace de la
contemplation
voilà le décor est posé il vous propose
maintenant d'entraînant différents
questionnements
la première question tourne autour de
peut-on accomplir sans persévérance
immédiatement on a le sentiment que la
réponse est non pensez vous qu'il omet
que bâtir que quand souilhe s'obtient
sans l'effort clairement clairement
c'est pas possible
la réponse est non et que ce soir
exemple astres sa baignoire avec son
oreca que ce soir aux morts avec ses
peintures que ce soit alexandra ses
plans tous
tous ont une intuition qui les pousse
vers le but à atteindre
chacun sa manière à son niveau s'impose
son propre but que l'effort dans la
durée je dis bien dans la durée pas
l'énerver tabac plier si c'était tout
simple si ce n'était pas évident
d'autres l'auraient déjà fait le
laboureur consent à cet effort car il
sait que le blé récolté sera à ceux qui
ont déjà renoncé et qui viendront lui
acheter
l'inventeur par sa volonté pas se
rentrer au qu'on craint de la
connaissance
il devra dépasser les limites
il sortira du cadre traditionnel car
toujours l'innovation se trouve au
dollar elle est derrière le mur des
connaissances les limites résiste il
faudra aller au delà de la nuit du
conventionnel or cette même convention
produisent un doute fort pour l'esprit
ce qui ne les rebelles pas en
perspective ont naturellement tendance
par conservatisme à s'opposer aux forces
créatrices qui combattent vaciller les
rentes et l'a bien fait
notre cerveau est ainsi structuré il
procède pour ne pas se fatiguer et être
pratique d'abord et avant tout par
réflexe mais quand il faut changer les
câblages neurones où il commence par
rejeter il faut par la porte de l'effort
le bon peintre lui d'abord puis les
autres de partager les nouvelles
conceptions pour cela bien sûr il trop
du tombe il faut de la volonté et en un
mot
il faut de la persévérance une autre
question maintenant la persévérance et
vertueuse
à cette question le plus facile est
reconduit oui oui la persévérance c'est
une vertu il le fait d'avoir un but
structure une vie et lui donne un sens
disposer d'un mur nous permet de voir au
delà de notre simple égaux le but c'est
comme un point dans l'espace à partir
duquel il est possible de bâtir
l'architecturé de tout l'univers
mais si la persévérance est une vertu
est-ce que l'ex id celle-ci ne conduit
pas à la destruction de celui qui la
porte tous les maux qui caractérisent
une ex et son opiniâtreté acharnement
jusqu'où faut-il aller dans son rêve
faut-il accepter de berne y compris sa
propre vie certains inventeurs ont été
victimes de l'entreprise invention et là
je lui une petite liste qui commence par
al jarreau et ingénierie en 1008 qui
désirent évolué mais malheureusement il
a tenté de traverser la manche
il s'est écrasé william buller en 1860
il a inventé des rotatives de presse
mais un jour dans son atelier il a
laissé son pied traîner dans une
courroie la machine l'a détruit ils
france tricheurs en 1911 s'est jeté du
haut de la tour eiffel et porter le
premier par la suite marie crise est
grande sa vente en 1934 des gourous et
meurent à cause de la radioactivité et
on peut citer encore n'importe comment
donald campbell en 1966 qui se sont
wendel bloopers cassette dépasse le
record de vitesse avant de se retourner
et être englouti ses hommes
ces drames ont fait pour deux c'est
l'humanité mais la persévérance les a
détruits faut-il accepter le sacrifice
de sa vie pour aller jusqu'à son but
obiang doit-il existait une limite à la
persévérance nord qu'un seul risque
c'est à la fois réducteur insuffisant et
égocentrique et je reviens sur chacun de
ces points
c'est l'éditeur car tout est organisé et
construit à partir d'un seul prix
qui réduit le champ du réel et qui par
effet de symétrie empêche de prendre
conscience de la richesse et de la
diversité du compte c'est insuffisant
certaines du premier livre de john
steinbeck premier livre que j'ai bien
tapé dans son roman de cape town lundi
d'un sauveteur sa grande question c est
que les tons quand louis xiv la vie à ce
moment là at elle encore un sens cette
peur de la réalisation d'une ligne
conduit certains à renoncer en chemin a
préféré s'arrêter de façon à conserver
l'illusion qu'un jour il pourrait
éventuellement arriver et le dernier
point c'est égocentrique tout sacrifier
à sa passion à son plan intérieur
certes ces vertueux mais à condition que
le minutes il poursuivi le soir ni
avocat ni seulement donné vers soi même
ainsi ce héros de la mythologie vert qui
à force de salaberry
et sans pauvreté dans le reflet du lac a
fini par s'y voyez donc l'excellence la
persévérance c'est pas toujours
passionné mais est ce qu'on peut trouver
un équilibre dans cette persévérance
pour qu'au crépuscule d'une vie on
puisse considérer qu'elle a bien été
remplies il faut un but et des peep toe
structurer son action il faut financer
d'aller jusqu'au bout de ses talents et
peu importe contre qui nous était le
départ l'important c'est de l'avoir
exploité il voue toujours choisir la
voie de l'innovation celle d'autres
n'ont pas su voir on refusait de voir et
je rendrai la un discours de steve job
aux étudiants de stanford il y disait il
leur dit en guise de testament
soyez insatiables soyez francs c'est le
voeu que j'ai toutefois mener pour moi
c'est le voeu que je formule pour vous
il faut aussi garder à l'esprit que
l'individu que nous sommes l'existant
que dans le rapport à autrui
je ne dirais pas comme une rené
descartes je pense donc je suis
mais bien plus je suis l'ombre il faut
que mon action personnelle s'inscrit
dans une démarche qui transcende
l'individu et qui la dépasse le lui ne
doit pas satisfait
seulement monsonego mais se projeter
dans un cadre plus large celui de la
recherche en général de l'amélioration
de la condition humaine du récit des de
mes proches du respect de ma nation il
faut des bassins cette contraction
d'égoïste du moi qui tu es un rayon
laser concentre la volonté sur un seul
but ultime le cadre de la vie doit être
élargi et intégrer des notions d'éthique
et positionner cette démarche dans le
respect de l'être collective qui nous
constitue et sans lequel cet étrange cet
ego ce mois ne veut même pas se
concevoir ce chemin d'amélioration je le
dirai en guise de clin d'oeil ce chemin
d'amélioration individuel dans le
respect et pour l'autre c'est là le vrai
qui râle le seul le mans celui de
l'élévation de la 40 mais on ne naît pas
humain on le devient
et pour clôturer cette intervention
je voudrais me citer un extrait d'un
poème de rudyard kipling écrit ans
1910 que je vous engage à rechercher sur
internet à un privé rendre et a gardé
près car il sera d'un grand réconfort
dans les moments où il faudra tenue dans
l'adversité
j'ai pris que les deux dernières
strophes que je me permets de vous lire
si tu peux rencontrer triomphe après des
verts et recevoir ces demandeurs d'un
même front
si tu peux conserver ton soir est à
thèse quand tous les autres les perdront
alors terroir les dieux la chance et la
victoire seront lents à tout jamais des
esclaves soumis
et ce qui vaut mieux que les rois et la
gloire
tu seras un homme mon fils